I'll say some things that are spoilers
that you will for everyone
reveal when it's right right I think we
have some unfinished business to talk
about this a little bit more about love
is she a match for Joe in some way she a
worthy adversary a mental foe how would
you describe her she is theoretically a
perfect match because she wants to see
somebody the way that Joe wants to be
seen and vice versa wait what did I just
say she wants to see somebody the way
Joe wants to be seen and vice versa
that's actually true yes yes it is it is
they both want to be seen they both
actually you understand more and more
she has a mania there too and so here's
the spoiler part that once you
understand why love is the way she is
and who she actually is you realize that
there is no perfect match for Jill
because actually he's found her but
that's the thing it's like we are too
accustomed to being like if she didn't
find the box they'd be together like no
he was always gonna you know with the
first season like that was always gonna
happen people like Joe cannot receive
what they want because they want
something impossible it's not just I
feel like when we see what loves
character is then then it's like oh yeah
oh yeah of course like he did find a
soulmate and he's and he turned her into
a villain you know he's split second you
did it again didn't you the big twist in
episode 9 hmmm everybody's gonna freak
out about this is she a serial killer
she on Joe's level how did you react to
finding out that she was a murderer - I
knew that she was the whole time but I
didn't know that Joe would then hear for
it I the thing that got me through
episodes 1 through 8 was like I mean at
least at least he's got somebody you
know you know because Joe clang Joe is
just it's a really it can be a really
isolating an intense thing for five and
a half months at a time right cuz yeah
for me it's not so much that she's a
killer because it's like okay yeah
theoretically they're the same but but
then it's like oh but then he but then
he he denies her which again brings up
this kind of the archetypes of man and
woman and how you know the oppression of
women the inequality of men and women
this this is this is the this is
actually why you don't actually really
have that many female serial killers
it's like there's something happen I
mean I don't have any phd's I don't know
but it's like there's something there
there's something to that
there's something to the fact that men
behave the way they do and women tend to
not do the same thing so what is that I
don't know but I feel like that's that's
what we see is it she doesn't appear to
be the same kind of person she doesn't
appear to be the same kind of predator
she doesn't appear to be the same kind
of you know they're I say thinking the
third Susan oh well let's talk about it
early no nothing about the third season
oh we're gonna get a third season I mean
technically I can't I mean like
unofficially but I'm not the person who
can say anything official so he's left
with this pregnant woman looking out the
window what is she looking for another
victim
he'll never stopped I was looking for
something that he can't I mean so the
way that I understand these things is
that no one is born a sociopath or
psychopath maybe that maybe the world of
Medicine hasn't decided definitively
but I'll go ahead and say that we're not
born that way were made that way we're
more mate were made that way by the by
the life we were then received the
education we received parents
environment whatever so I think Joe is
looking for that which was taken from
him as a child it's hard to have a fresh
start when the past is on your mind
there is a Gore factor though others
yeah more so than the first season I
think honestly a lot of what we did I
think they edited out I when I saw this
there's probably this particular
sequence you're thinking of from the
second episode lovely when I saw it I
was like wow they kind of I kind of
really reeled back on that one it wasn't
we had this very large prosthetic body
with limbs and everything no no head and
it was so real looking and feeling and I
was also covered in fact
which is very sticky because it's full
of sugar all right little fact so when I
was wrestling with this prosthetic body
which has on it
human hair real human hair individually
applied to that yeah I'm sorry I mean I
don't know you guys watch it I'm down I
didn't do it I didn't
I'm just the actor so between every take
I had was covered in sticky sugar red
blood and you know countless human hairs
that weren't on mine
actually I don't know whose they were
yeah stuck to my forearms you know like
so that was interesting after something
like that do you feel a little dark how
do you unwind when you go home you have
to watch an episode of a sitcom or
something no I mean for I've always said
I mean for me it's like it's a
meditation in prayer you're found you
know but I actually I don't struggle
with it in the way that you would think
I don't for me I leave Joe behind when
they said cut you know we may be within
reason but for me I just I think about
all these other things like these
conversations we're having like what
would you like to see happen to Joe I
mean is it possible is it is it would it
be even appropriate like let's say Joe
could somehow go through all these
experiences where he could be where
where we could all be like I think he
deserves I think he deserves something
better now you know like I I'm not sure
that that's possible so I think what is
Joe named Joe needs Joe needs Joe Joe
needs justice but what does that mean
like does that mean prison does that
mean death I don't know maybe he needs
to get murdered
we don't know okay he in he inevitably
will be right I mean he has to be how
else would this end how else could you
do this for many more seasons or is it a
lot it's not up to me
I yeah I don't know I mean I think like
you know yeah my lips are sealed on that
maybe I should run but I don't want to
[Music]